citizens of the reject Nation it is time
to conclude the
dcamu because today we are watching
Apocalypse war and guess what we haven't
seen it nope because that's how this
works please do leave a like please do
subscribe for not already and please do
leave a comment recommending the thing
we watch next because once this ends
frankly all bets are off we're gonna
stick with DC for a while there's a lot
of good DC we haven't watched but the
universe ends today and that is very
exciting speaking of universes ending
flash may have concluded that universe
but you know it hasn't ended Batman and
you should check out the bat verse shirt
yes these lovelies have over at
shopzeroeddition.com and if you want to
also support these lovelies please come
to San Diego Comic-Con on Saturday we've
got a panel the big day they give us a
big day panel San Diego Comic-Con real
rejects paneling it up we are very
excited so hope to see you there I think
without further Ado if you want to be a
patron you can watch this front to back
start to finish with our resting faces
otherwise it's time to get into it let
us War
all right who's gonna be driving today
[Music]
a little tiny little uh Mini Cooper
the apocalypse job yes a pocket car
apocacon
I like the idea of a buckles and Mini
Cooper though that's strong it's gray
like a gunmetal
[Music]
here's hoping
that I love you
didn't think that was in dousy the legal
sold this out and we'll be having pints
by Sundown absolutely true I hope that
we get to end this on a Constantine
movie yeah that's great excited
will Hawkman speak
as it was now or never this is
apocalypse Homeworld of Darkseid
Raven what's wrong it's nothing
no it's not it's never nothing Raven
what's your daddy saying up there these
are images from Worlds that Darkseid has
conquered
oh we have to attack there's always a
deal to be made let's at least send an
Envoy to apocalypse no
yeah nah Darkseid created a monster that
nearly killed me what chance would
Humanity have our only option is to
destroy him
that means Earth could be Ground Zero in
World War world's War yeah the main team
will attack through this entryway in
Apocalypse
members of the Titans shall remain on
Earth as a Home Guard
and only Power demons to guard him
Darkseid will be vulnerable to attack oh
he's invited to the meeting he's just
checking out honey please get somewhere
safe I may not be able to fight this war
but I can report the story
worrying super Apple watch I was gonna
say who made this watch I want one
use his own home screen for a second
love that guy ah look at how great I am
I Am the Man of Steel aren't uh man of
tomorrow
canonically I think that speech should
have came from Batman but you know I
feel like Superman saying to strike
first isn't exactly it but anyway
one I get that he was almost killed I
get his Vengeance but I still feel like
between the two koi if there's even a
one percentage
when Lex Luthor's like maybe let's not
be antagonists I love that he's still
part of the league too it's just hanging
out it's just testing how far he can get
in one of these meetings
they're too big to be parademons
then what the hell are those things
flying monkeys Sarah devils wow
yep intense
we're gonna be blending Titans league
and darkness it's exciting Boogie
oh
this has clearly gone well
beautiful
spoilers I guess it didn't work out
desolate but beautiful the glands are
full of whiskey I mean lots of whiskey
VHS are gonna be a breeze after the G's
[Music]
we need him John it's me
Clark Kent you knew me as Superman
what's up with your eyes oh it is you
now you've done it
stop it
I mean a chair chair probably not gonna
do this throw the bar at him I can't
oh he's got like Kryptonite in him whoa
that's messed up little help would be
nice
yes yes
now spit a bar at the bar
bloody nuisance well there's no sense
come on man you have one job aside from
killing you know demons also being a
demon
and I'm sober again
magic can be such a
I love this all super and magical Heroes
have problems staying drunk yeah it
burns right through gift from dark side
liquid Kryptonite they keep me from ever
being a threat
cruel booger off Clocky I told you he
was a waste of time all cowards are oh
now you've done it I didn't lead us all
into a massacre you did
Zatanna was a hero who fought bravely no
but where were you when she needed you
most no I love them together yeah
Zatanna would want you to hear us out
below the belt Boy Scout come with if
you want what about you etragon
who refilled your beer etch again
whatever
the whatever League what does it rhyme
with come on so much rhymes with
whatever
shoe leather why I never been all mopey
ever since a friend of his died
doesn't even rhyme anymore oh no
Darkseid knew every part of our plan
those things that attacked us were half
parademon half doomsday no
paradoomsday Darian Hal fought hard
but we're taken down no love them
Shazam
Jeremy Johns
Shazam was wounded I think Black Adam
was the other one
oh no that was him
oh foreign
they always jack up cyborg in the most
horrible ways that's brutal
tell me Batman made it somehow there's
somehow some
he had plans for
yep
I will test my tattoo gun out on you
[Applause]
oh that's so messed up
no
I don't know why I ran been up against
all sorts of bastards and I always stood
tall
because you didn't have your five
o'clock shadow we just need a locator
spell I need some gear so sit tight
etragon continue loafing done
I do like Mo Pietro again hope he Rhymes
at the very end when things go well yes
yes yes Solace the finale will get a
rhyme with apocalypse
foreign
City I like that gotta see it still with
that ordinance the Guardians of owa will
be forced to Bow before me the Damage
Done To The Apocalypse reactor during
the attack two years ago your attack
my solution is working oh the power
generated is less than your previous
reactor it sounds like the Batman a
major ship looks like the Batman molding
didn't fully transform you into a
capable servant perhaps you'd serve me
better as a Mindless drone
oh wow I am still your most competent
acolyte Lord Darkseid your former
teammate Luthor believes otherwise
yes
he does who am I finding Damien Wayne oh
I have to conjure a portal from scratch
big enough for all of us oh and everyone
has to stay still while I'm sick
no you're too weak why are we careful
everything will go according to
darkseid's schedule do you know if I'm
included in his lordship's plans
don't worry about your place in those
plans worry about doing what I tell you
oh of course Batman
he's such a sniveler now Lex Luthor
curious what level of long game Batman
must be playing to like yeah right It's
gotta be gotta be a betrayer
assassins
hey come on buddy you love yourself some
challenge
oh
no it'd be so hard to like have to learn
how to defend yourself when all your
life it's been like incredibly easy
don't feel a thing die demon
[Music]
oh yeah
Talia
oh no Damian
oh they're his people I know you hate me
but I wouldn't be here if it wasn't
necessary I'll let you live
for now if you bring me a fresh
turtleneck I've been out for years and
frankly that's all I know my neck is
cold
outside
you're not getting out father
Release Me
or I will kill the boy
no you harm one hair on Damien's head
steal anything and I'll cut your hands
off
oh I really like that
you two should team up Damien and
natural Damian demon there's some Rhymes
in there big work Batman believed in you
you cost me my father and my teammates
oh
whoa yeah
damn oh Nightwing
oh oh I was afraid that was almost about
oh that was bad about having you just
got here look you even got a line in
this movie nope damn there are always
risks in war he said he's not saying
that anymore
oh oh
no help us fix things he overcame my
mother's brainwashing once if anyone
could survive darkseid's programming
hippy father oh yeah but the only way to
apocalypse is to use the boom tube in
Lex Corp Tower
how do you expect to do that
let me make some calls finally beat the
crap out of Lexus
I'm thinking about this for years she's
a people person so I'm sure the
Situation's well in
hand
wow
Lois and Harley yes what
Lois she looks like she can handle
herself come on Ollie Havana cold one
what a couple of fun Sheila's beat each
other bloody Amos
of course Boomerang got lines here and
of course he's like completely Untouched
by all of this everything's fine Aussies
Palms convicts
do your best time
the most Superman line yet that was so
good I love that
at Constantine and Boomerang together
perfect moments you gotta be kidding
he always
gotta be kidding this scene's full of
bars this is a good scene yeah
[Applause]
nicely done
The Sting ladies and gents of The
Suicide Squad because tomorrow
we take back this planet we died in Hell
Lois got everyone decided her via fist
fight with Harley Quinn I love that
magic that's so good oh bullets is my ex
you and Harley
do I look mad
yes yes
that's right queer icon John Constantine
great how did Amanda Waller let a
lunatic like you become leader of the
squad she died
the card didn't work that's perfect
setup from that oh that's so good we'll
be taking our cut from Luthor Supply
train since this show started nice
real Robin Hood types Rob from the rich
and sell to the poor
give to the poor
huh
they're doing a good job tying up a lot
of loose ends so how'd you end up with
Kent you left and I was alone
I just wanted to end the pain
God how do you get back
I mean dark stuff might have been put in
there is like a lesson see Superman
walking around broken that's like yeah
I'm around the whole planet's down and
then the place that should give him
power Korea's not yeah I had feelings
for you
if you didn't you made the right
decision I left because my father wants
to kill you I couldn't risk that
the heck are they
they phased the Earth magma to
darkseid's base and they're playing it
up we plan on mounting simultaneous
attacks on two of the machines why not
attack all three we don't have enough
people
yeah I was thinking that dark side is
going to owa once we're there we shut
down the portal so he can't come back
how do you know he'll be gone
did you steal his diary
yes you have a source in darkseid's Camp
called sleeper he or she has been
slipping me information for months or
they Batman
I know this plan has astronomical risks
and impossible odds you're the suicide
squad
blah blah blah let's do this thing
yes sir so it's actually justice league
dark suicide Titans apocalypse War he
has the original working title it's uh
it's a bit of a journey
who are these guys
wowie king shark is a shark my friend
here was to attack my thugs we killed
him right back yep yeah just siree Bob
you betcha gotta get my friend to a duck
how are you can we go
I mean it worked glorious not a bad
American accent Boomer I go to claim owa
for my Empire do not interrupt me this
is my private time my private murder
time of lanterns now that my arms are
crossed I will not uncross them
he does the
all right it's hard to cross back there
yeah it's good stretch though it is
feels nice yeah everyone at home stretch
I'm sending the signal to attack the
machines China team is engaged
box office numbers
it's got like a gold leg of energy yeah
I wonder where she went after she kicked
me out the house
hey
guys we never did get our house movie
yeah
oh Batman Beyond is beyonding
whoa or is it batwing oh it's like yeah
that guy that's right yeah Batman Beyond
it this universe will be sick though
yeah I forgot we got that whole team
introduction in Universe yeah 30 person
cast I'm not getting a signal that any
of the paradums have left apocalypse
another debacle Damien geez we should
have gathered a third Force this is my
fault it's a debocolypse
oh
I thought I'd pop by to discuss
fertilizer and the such
yes yes my dude
one day
one day they're leaving already
but just know that this thing here will
be the death of your precious screen
I'm listening here's your third team in
one love it the green
green well not die yes yes oh damn dude
Swamp Thing super effective astral
projection solve the whole thing yep
what did you say that day why did you
say that game that game
how did you play that game
that was good that's how we finish the
the dciw combination that's where we got
to that's we're gonna be proud yeah
that's how they Omega for etragonal rap
over the credits yes Will Smith style he
has to say every team that's in the
movie yeah and rhyme it and every
character individually
yes
everyone in the universe fighting yes
what a culmination
[Music]
[Laughter]
amazing oh
glad it's all rated for her
best boss ever
you sure sign me up
[Music]
dang shot in the face I think shiva's
had like a couple small appearances
through this yeah she's had her little
little cameos yeah but someone had to
get a shot in the face to show the
stakes
oh
it's not going around
my camera
Furious
I hope you actually are Luther what the
hell what is this this way keep it
moving gang you said this would be hard
it's not hard a repeat word technically
Rhymes all right all right he's getting
there he's warming up yeah
I'm afraid you don't have the proper
clearance
okay
ouch
[Music]
nice
what a great line cold
no one will mourn you I was surrounded
and the battle was over I had to make a
choice
I've been helping Lois ever since uh I
was wondering if that was the bait and
switch because it's not Batman yeah yeah
who changed sides when it suited him
that's also what makes you think she
won't do it again he wants to be a hero
deep down and he does want to save the
planet that's kind of his thing yeah I
was hoping Alex would have some kind of
face-ish and then it's that life
equation actually corrupting Batman yeah
[Music]
as a team to himself
oh oh
so Much Death
whoa dude
I was gonna say I wonder where his
personality is like now messy do you
want me to add your soul to my ledger my
body has to be more than dead huh the
last accursed Dagger of a Stover keep
daddy in his pen and we won't have to go
down that road I can do it you got this
I believe in you
oh
fires Kryptonite infused missiles and
high explosive rounds
perfect for paradums hey but you made it
to kill my husband if I had issues
don't look a gift horse in the mouth you
know
so many Kryptonite weapons make sense
Lois you someone has to make sure the
portal stays closed
come back to me Smallville
[Music]
ah Smallville she just wanted the show
renewed yeah
I'm willing you know and Rosenbaum the
best Lutheran absolutely Luthor there's
been unauthorized use of the portal from
lexcorp just to power surge Batman it's
nothing already handled all hail Dark
Side
you finally decided to reveal your
traitorous nature Lord Darkseid will
kill you slowly excellent well I guess
I'm completely on your side now
oh that's so good only at that moment
yeah I'm completely on your team oh
that's good
I like how chilly is just floating
around there she's doing it
wow
oh kilowog
teleport a portion of Earth's magma here
I'd like to make a point jeez ugh
[Music]
that's dark
God damn it oh
[Music]
oh cyborg mirror
damn
whoa
oh Martian Manhunter
all their friends oh
damn
so icky the furies are rough oh man
Diana
I'm sorry this happened to you
yes seriously Corey it's me you're being
controlled
they salvaged like the two halves yeah
[Music]
Hawkman looks like a nightmare these
Furies are terrifying yeah
oh easy princess
there he is
yes my dude
go off Wonder Woman cyborg versus
etrahan
[Music]
nice that's a good shot
ow oh
yeah
do you bleed cause I do
[Music]
Oh I thought he had her no this is gonna
make him more excited and love will get
a giggle out of him might not get that
that rhyme scheme my race is run I
regret nothing
huh
it was fun
[Music]
last second got it in there
he died as he lived spitting bars
we've got final bar
oh fun you were a paragon for warriors
Through the Ages not dark sides minion
Break Free now
whoa cool
nice
pair of Constantine compels you that was
cool Diana at the mascara yes
yes
there's a tunnel behind you leading to
the power generator
leave them to me
[Music]
I mean I guess it's hard to wake people
up when they're all attacking you at
once yeah
for Clark and the team to have any
chance those monsters can't get back to
apocalypse last call then Kryptonite
whiskey buckle up suicide squatties
today's the day we earn our name Lois
and likes of The Suicide Squad
it's beautiful
what oh poor Barry no
it's just been running this whole time
no oh that's awful and that's just Barry
he doesn't look all like fried out oh
I mean he does but you know not like not
corrupted I'm possessed just trapped
yeah
[Music]
whoa it was phased on a mega Bean hit a
apocalypse reactor damage converted me
to replacement make it stop you gotta
make me stop
oh God
sleep late
ah oh
he caused it if he doesn't go back to
save his mum dark side is in here we go
through
what are you planning Constantine
it's magic you wouldn't understand
[Music]
oh I just ripped that guy's spine out
whoa Mortal Kombat
glad they all get their moments
nice oh
I'll kill you boy
not great none can resist dark side
[Music]
what is happening
It's Gonna Hurt
oh I didn't expect that he's connected
to them all that's fantastic we got some
folks back now they're like those toys
in Toy Story that look evil but aren't
yes Batman stepped out to talk to the
big Batman's return
and with his Lord and Master
you well
ouch I thought that was gonna go but she
won't pick us apart so easily father
you dare call me that what did you say
that name
your mother drugged me to conceive you
goaded me into raising you and broke me
mentally I see you were never my son nah
only a burden come then and your burden
once and for all yes
Batman with no conscience I would not
want to fight
[Applause]
come on
Jesus
Bruce don't ah
Crime Alley
finish you
oh
go to hell yes
leaving the bat slave yes you disappoint
me ugh
no oh
oh damn
[Music]
do it
whoa
[Music]
I'm offering you a willing magical host
wow I have a better idea
no no
whoa whoa
what
what ah
I did not see that Counting
so many are dead come on push double
eyes that's how you do it yes
oh an emperor father
Justice
not vengeance
sad Batman guess me man oh Lois
Bruce
40 seconds
send the message to Clark's mech suit
now so we can see it good to have you
back bets yeah
I know we planned on always being
together
but that's not going to happen now Lois
oh
what is this
oh damn
Captain Boomerang is a boomerang snuggle
it's been an honor to fight by your side
geez are you me
hahaha
[Laughter]
amazing we all understand king shark now
now we're part of the family we're part
of the suicide squad
wow
yes
whoa
is
let's go he's back and he got shaved
real quick little Kryptonite shape yeah
is Damian's sword
yes
[Music]
nah wait on him
yes
ah yeah
we'll need Constantine
well that's a problem
oh hello John but how in the hell did
you get me into heaven
I needed to apologize for making you run
away when I died huh
oh wow
a compulsion spell
let's see
he thought we should have a backup plan
in case everything went wrong
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay our friends still need your help
I'm dead you of all people should know
that means nothing when Destiny's
involved
[Music]
I love you
oh
yes
tears
[Music]
wow cool
holy he's alive
oh oh
dang Vic do we have a way out working on
it
come on
oh guys
don't make this overly emotional father
it wasn't your fault
you've already deployed the bat hug
we're good Pat bonding accomplished yes
we're not leaving Clark behind Darkseid
needs to be distracted for me to do my
thing
yeesh
you can't be serious uh-huh
you have Spirit Kryptonian with the
strength of a lost love is
what were you saying
let's go
unless you would fight me for the right
to destroy him nah we good
I got my licks oh
yep yep yep
what a wonderful gift daughter
well
at peace
goodbye father
looks like I get the last word yes
suck it yes
[Music]
yes
off into Oblivion
look at that
[Music]
t for Triumph what up giant movie yeah
right that was a lot a thick boy that
was a lot of moving Parts like eight C's
on that man we lost 31 of the Earth's
molten core
the planet's rotation is compromised
the smallest change either way will mean
freezing or burning wow you know what
you have to do mate start again
another flash point oh
it won't be perfect
it'll be a long side better than what we
got now
yeah truly
oh
go Barry
[Music]
yes
damn
oh
at last
into Oblivion
I love that it ended to the Trinity yeah
wow dude that was intense that was that
was a crazy one man yeah that was big
and and thick and so many things they
did and had to do in accomplishing
successfully and wow yeah that's the
crazy part about so many of these movies
and especially the more aventi ones the
more sort of like every player is on the
board like yeah it's like
we got an hour 25 minutes to to make
this feel like a two and a half hour
movie and somehow they're really good at
doing that I can't believe that was a
Batman movie and a Suicide Squad movie
and a dressless league movie and a
justice league dark movie and Teen
Titans movie and an Apocalypse movie and
like that was crazy
yeah like we we knew them well because
but I don't know how John certain Swamp
Thing got cast first but good for them
sure uh
knowing everyone already obviously gave
us a lot of Shemar Moore was hybrid
that's cool yeah
um knowing everyone already was
obviously a huge asset but they did so
much Tony Todd as dark side Rebecca
Romaine is Lois Lane thought I
recognized the voice uh but man they did
so much more than I thought possible in
one 90 minute movie I know right that
was insane yeah and like again not
overcrowded like every it really people
got moments yeah and it's very rewarding
after all of the movies that have led up
to it too don't think it would have been
without them no totally really had to go
the way we went yeah
I would be very fascinated like I bet
this would still be quite thrilling to
peer in on if you just watched only this
but yeah it's like not being invested in
Suicide Squad they'd just be like one
note joke whereas like here I was like
oh they're Landing their like long arcs
yeah and and yeah not only with them but
with various other characters as well
and yeah you get payoffs for the Teen
Titans you get things wrapped around for
Constantine for Superman and Lois for
the Batman and Dame in storyline like so
many things long uh you know payoffs of
like the cancer thing with Amanda Waller
that are truly set up in other films
that like have to go here yeah and like
the lesson of Damien being taught to
Bruce there are things I would tweak
though like I I would have loved a
moment where Bruce had like you know was
in the middle of enacting Vengeance at
dark side and he had to listen to
Damien's advice sure I would have loved
to see it's still I mean it would have
been a simple writing tweak to have it
be Superman uh enacts something that is
too
um soft like Batman got two different
speech yeah so Batman gets the opening
speech he's like we have to strike first
we strike now and then he's unsuccessful
because Superman says we can't be
murderers and that's why everybody won't
blame Superman and that's how Batman
gets corrupted that makes way more sense
than like why was the opening like
Vengeance Superman I get that he was
almost killed I get all those things
that's not Superman I get the yeah and I
do agree it's all you change and it
fixes everything it doesn't it's not uh
uh like to me it was the kind of thing
where I was like I can see a version of
Superman who just like reads the writing
on the wall and was like yeah this isn't
gonna go well and we have to get ahead
of the game but it still doesn't feel a
hundred percent like
something Superman would do or say and I
can see him supporting it but not
enacting it I can see it being like you
know what Batman's right we have another
Choice and then in the moment going like
we can't do this like that to me would
have made both allotments work yeah
you're like a knocking
did you heard that too right yeah it
sounded like it was outside that wall
weird
hello
there's a ghost in the room it's a very
it was very loud like I don't know I've
recorded hundreds of hours here as a
view that was crazy what happened there
but yeah I just feel like that was
something that bothered me but like that
that I'd change just certain
characterizations of this universe never
quite rang true to me but man that's my
only negative like it was so much
positive yeah that did feel kind of like
ah you know not that I know the 100 like
oh they're trimming the trees ah this is
it's literally right outside there's a
lot of real life going there's a lot and
it's very distracting apology I had to
acknowledge it yeah it felt like kind of
a beat that that might have been like
truncated from an earlier draft Yeah
because I do agree with that it seems
like much more of a Batman philosophy to
be like we should strike like any time
striking first and a tactical plan yeah
yeah 100 the plan a plan and yeah and
like a fully thought out like I am you
like there's three of us do this yeah
totally totally and then maybe because
of the Betrayal of Superman not enacting
it uh his rage allows dark decides life
equation to get in its head and then
he's corrupted like yeah there are
things that would have served all of it
better yeah that's absolutely but I
really liked how they had the time Jump
so we got to be like whoa the world's
messed up and then you you slow burn
discover what happened to everyone I
really enjoyed the like okay we've
discovered having this team oh there's
another team oh we've got a it like
really narratively paced well yeah
because that was a crazy name and it
drew just the circumstances and who
would be corrupted who would perish and
who would be left you know as the sort
of dregs trying to figure out one
last-ditch attempt at saving everything
like I thought the displacement of
everybody was really nice and yeah the
way that they gradually you know worked
up to the the ultimate plan of how do we
stop this and and yeah having that
one-two punch of like dark sides coming
and he's gonna you know reshape the
Earth and steal our research you know we
gotta act now and then immediately cut
to and we failed miserably and uh and
now we gotta undo this and yeah to have
all that effort go toward vanquishing
dark side but then realizing that it's
too late really yeah and there's just
gonna be worse just it's like we stopped
the immediate threat but things are only
going to get worse damage is done now we
gotta reset again like it it felt like
kind of a worthy way to end such a a
lengthy Arc of movies but that you know
will never stop being made yeah so like
yeah to do that just brilliant white you
know white light absorbing everything
was really nice and I did like that it
felt like well we tried these heroes are
heroes but there was no coming back but
they still won yeah that's what I'm
saying like it was it was both things
yeah it's it's a fun Nuance of an ending
because yeah it's like we won the battle
but we didn't win the overall war and
that's what we need to now you know go
back and literally resetting a universe
because of the like Horrors yeah and two
I feel like it doesn't to me it doesn't
like negate or cheapen anything that
came before to have the reset happen
because it's like we wouldn't have been
able to do that if we lost we would have
lost everything things would have only
gotten you know worse person words and
words Dark Side would have conquered all
yeah and now at least we have Barry back
so that we can in order to reset yeah
and no one else could have done it I
also love that Constantine and Flash
basically became the leads that's the
thing too is is in a movie like this I I
was pleasantly surprised by it I like
that in a lot of I think Constantine
appearances he does sort of like rise to
being something of a crucial player or a
semi-leader and an also audience Cipher
all in one yeah and in a movie like this
you know you expect like oh Batman
Superman are probably going to be the
most prominent and it's like John
Constantine it's it's like an ensemble
piece certainly and it's not just
focused on him it's not like the
Constantine movie but at the same time
he does kind of
yeah like even over Harley Quinn even
over Batman like even over yeah and I
really like that when it was on The
Suicide Squad it let it be a Suicide
Squad movie yeah like I always talk
about how hard it is to like an artist
Jam page where it's like Jim Lee drawing
and capullo drawing and top McFarland
and like they managed to make this all
feel authentic to each other's teams in
one big long title movie yeah I was so
impressed man this was really
spectacular and like I I've talked a lot
about like my you know version of these
characters I've came to love this take
on them enough that I was so invested in
them at this this ending yeah well to
get a few I know we've talked a lot
about romance and passion and this
wasn't like super focused on those but
we did get a couple of loving wrap-ups
with people at the end Starfire
Nightwing her broken and like a fury in
him like insane yeah that was brutal but
but reunited and the last thing Lois and
Clark got to have their moment together
like I love you there were so many of
those Great Moments yeah and those I
thought you know those made it sort of
feel like even though again it's not
been like the main flavor of this whole
journey it made it feel like yeah that
stuff was always there it's always been
growing and this was a nice way to put a
human a personal an emotional stamp as
well as the cool action and the Sci-Fi
and all that stuff and yeah just like
putting the stamp on the story itself uh
yeah I was impressed yeah and the array
of magic and powers and the whole thing
was zatana too it was really cool tying
it all back into magic like because
that's the thing that can defeat
Superman tying the Kryptonite that Lex
would have there was really good long
game villainy and and solves yeah and
and two having it be like okay Lex is
the one feeding them info Batman really
has been corrupted yeah it's a deeper
kind of saving in order and then it was
the other obvious but it was just tricky
enough that I didn't think of it yeah
yeah yeah and two I I really thought the
beat of Constantine being like why did I
run and and blaming myself I love that
being yeah and drinking himself to death
out of guilt yeah like feeling so guilty
and ashamed of that decision that
ultimately actually wasn't a decision I
thought was so lovely and to it and
Batman it makes Batman even cooler I
love how like good writing makes Batman
the coolest yeah he was like you know
what might happen um
spell on unconstantine yeah and I love
the constant immediately was like
he didn't blame her he blamed Batman
immediately that's exactly
I love that yeah and that also made it
like I was sad to not have Zatanna
because like in her brief appearances I
really liked her presence and her
rapport with Constantine all that stuff
but like I thought that made really nice
bookends for this and that that
satisfied my heart and the romance was
lovely and then Heaven scene was great
and and Trigon had fun etragon and he
went out on a rhyme and not only on a
rhyme but on the rhyme about him having
fun having fun this one thing took out
an entire third of the problem I love
this swampy got to be like awesome this
really did a great job giving a lot of
people their due yeah totally I was
wondering how he came back but I'm not
thinking too too hard about that because
I think the last time we saw him he was
like they did like wither him away oh
yeah but uh I'm sure that's okay the
green brought him back yeah he just had
a Little Seedling yeah
I know James Gunn loves these movies so
I'm really excited to see if he can I
mean imagine if he can build the like
something like that that would be
amazing like that would make Avengers La
Quint so is yeah yeah because this does
feel
interconnected but in ways you know it's
got an interesting blend of ways where
it's obvious how they're connected and
in ways in which it's not obvious until
much later all those different tones it
like feels like Infinity war and end
game and like the big team up so this
was and but this is 90 minutes I want to
see 40 movies lead to something like
this I know I want the next 10 years of
my life to lead to something this crazy
absolutely oh well I think that is going
to do it uh this was an absolute
spectacular uh we're gonna do something
to rank the DC AMU we're not sure the
format yet but uh just this Canon we're
gonna do a ranking of and then when we
get to the the big DC Pie in the Sky
what's crazy is while we keep watching
those more will come out but at some
point we'll go like we've seen 50 or
something but like we're gonna watch
like a swath of those but we're gonna
rank the DC AMU because I love me some
lists uh we'll we'll keep you guys
posted so leave a comment let us know
your ranking and how you think we should
rank them but before we get out of here
let's give some Patron love too
Chase Gardner you know why because Flash
because Flash has Chase Swamp Thing and
Swamp Thing that's actually perfect
perfect two players integral pieces of
this puzzle one is in the green and
one's gotta move fast Chase Gardner love
that good call that's you buddy you are
the person we would call upon the crisis
of infinite Earths of time of uh what
other crises uh I mean you hit the big
ones yeah I mean infinite crises crisis
has never heard said the two that I
think of there's just general crises to
start out the craze we need you for all
of them all any and all crisis we're
turning to you buddy because you're
steady frankly you're the strength that
can take out a third of the problem and
the one that has to take out the big
problem at the end because that's how
good you are so MVP situation Mr Chase
Gardner much appreciated the hero so
stay pledged buddy that keep your spot
at the top of of you know your league
yeah at the top of the league you know
we we all answer to you you know you're
like Our Benevolent dark side as well
there you go high price tied into the
whole kitten caboodle my friend but we
love you we appreciate your support
every month and we will catch you next
time Chase Gardner is
all right that's gonna do what you
lovelies we are done with the DC AMU we
will be back for something else TBD
leave a comment below hit that like
share this video all the things much
love reject Nation we'll see you soon